former first lady barbara Bush's family
says she is now receiving only comfort
care for her failing health mrs. blush
who is 92 is suffering from congestive
heart failure a family spokesman says
the wife of the 41st president and
mother of 43rd president has decided to
stop for their medical treatment
David beg no is outside the Bush's home
in Houston David good morning John good
morning the Bush's live right inside
that gated community here it is very
quiet here in Houston and has been for
the last 24 hours since we first got
this notice we are told there may not be
another public statement about mrs.
Bush's condition until she is quote
heaven-bound Barbara Bush the 92 year
old former first lady and matriarch of a
political dynasty has been in and out of
the hospital recently for a number of
health related issues including
bronchitis and Graves disease which she
has battled for decades in a statement
of family spokesman says it will not
surprise those who know her that Barbara
Bush has been a rock in the face of her
failing health worrying not for herself
thanks to her abiding faith but for
others USA TODAY's Washington bureau
chief Susan page is writing a biography
about mrs. Bush that is scheduled to be
published next year I started going to
Houston to interview her for this
biography last October and she was not
afraid of dying but she was still living
a life in a really full way Barbara Bush
is the second woman in history to be
both a wife and a mother of a u.s.
president her husband of 73 years George
HW Bush has also been battling health
problems in 2016 mrs. Bush spoke about
her family with Norah O'Donnell what do
you want the bush legacy to be the
children and the grandchildren they all
do something for others they do public
service they do something for others in
1990 mrs. Bush offered this advice to
the graduates of Wellesley College at
the end of your life you will never
regret not having passed one more test
winning one more verdict or not closing
one more deal you will regret time not
spent with a husband a child a friend or
a
and so by her side this morning is her
husband and their children Neil Marvin
and Dorothy George W Bush and Jeb Bush
are not here right now but we're told
they called a lot Barbara Bush told her
college about a year ago I'm still old
and I'm still in love with the man I
married 72 years ago and beyond a'right
now we're told a former president is by
his wife's side and all they do is hold
hands two are inseparable and they are
so beloved in Houston and what a model
role model she is as a former first lady
of this country all right and as the end
the way she's facing this moment with
peace peace and faith well sure all the
best right now David thank you